So just to be clear about this, we are allowing the
possibility that M equals zero and that gives us an empty sum,
which we can interpret as the zero matrix.
Now that we have the
concept of a projection at our disposal, we can define a more general
class of quantum measurements known as projective measurements.
This isn't the most general
notion of a measurement, but it is significantly more general than standard basis measurements
and it's going to be very
helpful to incorporate it into our description
of quantum information.
A projective measurement is defined by any set of projections
that satisfies the condition that you see right here, which is that the projections
sum to the identity matrix.
Here M can be any
positive integer you like so long as these are all projections and this condition is true,
the collection defines a
projective measurement.
The measurement described
by such a collection works as follows when you
measure any quantum state Psi.
First you get an outcome
between one and M, where M is the number of projections.
For each possible outcome, K, the probability to get that outcome is the Euclidean norm
squared of the vector you get
by multiplying S by Pi
K, the Kth projection.
We can also write this
quantity as you see right here.
This equality comes from the relationship between the Euclidean
norm and the inner product together with the fact
that Pi K is a projection.
From the second form, together with the condition that we have on these projections, we can see right away, by linearity, that our probabilities
will always sum to one,
keeping in mind that Psi
has to be a unit vector.
And second, assuming that
we get the outcome, K, the state of the system
collapses to the quantum state we get by normalizing whatever
vector we got by projecting.
We'll take a look at some
examples in just a moment, but before we do that, let me mention that we don't actually need
to number the possible
outcomes from one to M. We can choose whatever names or symbols we want for the outcomes.
In particular, if we have a collection of projections that are labeled with symbols
from sum set gamma say,
and they satisfy the
same condition as before, which is that they sum
to the identity matrix, then we have a projective measurement
that works in exactly
the same way as before.
The only only difference here is that we're allowing
the measurement outcomes to be elements of this set gamma as opposed to the integers from one to M.
For our first example of
a projective measurement, let's observe that
standard basis measurements are projective measurements.
In this case the set of
outcomes of the measurement is the same as the set of classical states of whatever system is being measured.
And the set of projections
that describes the measurement is this collection right here, assuming that sigma is
the classical state set
of our system. These are all projections
and if we sum them up, we get the identity matrix, so it's a valid projective measurement
To see how this works in
a little bit more detail, let's suppose that we
have some arbitrary state that's written in the form
that you see right here.
The probability for the
measurement to yield the outcome A, according to the description
from a moment ago, is this value right here,
which is equal to the
absolute value squared of the corresponding
entry of the vector Psi, which is what we expect.
Conditioned on the outcome being A, the state of the system becomes this, again, according to the
description from a moment ago.
If we simplify, we don't
quite get the state we expect, which is Ket A.
Instead we get Ket A
multiplied by a scaler, and specifically, this is a scaler having
absolute value equal to one,
so it's a complex number
on the unit circle.
This is called a global phase and we'll discuss global phases shortly, but for now in short, this
state is equivalent to Ket A.
This global phase doesn't
actually have any significance at all and we'll see why
when we get to the discussion of global phases.
So (unclear) this issue of global phases, which we'll talk about in just a moment, we see that standard basis measurements
are in fact projective measurements. For another example, which is really an extension
of the previous example,
if we perform a standard basis
measurement on a system X and we do nothing to a system Y, just like we talked about
in the previous lesson,
it's completely equivalent
to measuring the system X, Y.
With this projective
measurement right here.
We have these projections corresponding to the classical states of X and we're tensoring with the identity on Y
which reflects the fact that
we're not doing anything to Y.
The description for how
projective measurements work in general tells us
what happens in this example, and I'll leave it to you to
check that this is in fact
completely equivalent to what we discussed in the previous lesson.
This is all very nice because this projective
measurement description is cleaner in a way and we see that it fits into
this more general picture.